I'm just so sick to my stomach right now
not only does he have veteran credit uh
next to Fletcher Cox Jordan Davis for
like the next five years that is just
don't joke just having a Kobe Dean oh
yeah Nicole we're just Georgia North
yeah I just think it was like Jordan but
I'm just sick I'm just sick to my
stomach right now I'm just sick to my
stomach I can't believe that many teams
passed up one like this yeah it's gonna
be okay it's gonna be okay
I'm just truly just sick right now wow I
just uh you know what before we do the
pick let's go to AJ Brown uh AJ Brown
hey how you doing Eagles fan Adam lefko
here uh Jalen Carter is now your
teammate and people say he's the best
player in the draft and how he moved up
to get him at nine your thoughts
I would definitely say
Micah I know you want I know you just
just be a Philadelphia Eagle at this
point is great it's great organization
man come on he got Fletcher Cox Hassan
Reddick uh Jordan uh Davis uh to go to
go along with
man the defense is is crazy right then
the value of it they Harvey who just got
85 million and now you're coming now
you're going to pay someone for 20. you
know the value I'm just so shocked nine
teams eight teams let Jalen Carter fall
tonight for this come on man come on bro
just just come on over let's keep
talking for sure
the value that I pick is crazy you like
Javon Hargrave a 10 plug sack D tackle
go you get signed for 85 and you get the
value of 20 I mean that's the eight plus
pick like AJ AJ do it oh
hey